[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: Welcome back to 820.
So in this section, we want
to define events and frames.
The goal is to define the
principle of relativity.
So let's think first about
what an event actually is.
An event is something
that happens,
and it happens independently
of the frame of reference,
independently in how we want
to describe the event itself.
We might use the frame,
the reference frame,
to define the event.
But again, the event
is an independent thing
which happens.
Let's look at an
example, probably
one of my favorite
example in this class.
Guess what happens?
What?
Professor Kloots exploded.
Really?
And then you start asking the
questions, when and where.
When did it happen, and
where did it happen?
But the event happens
without a description
of the when and where.
We can then draw
a reference frame,
as I did here, with an
origin, with an x-coordinate,
and a y-coordinate,
and z-coordinate.
And in this picture, we have
a spot defined for the event.
And we need to also have a
fourth coordinate for this,
the time, in order to describe
when the event actually
happened.
And I did this here.
And some coordinates I give you.
It's 42 degrees north,
75 degrees west,
Cambridge, Massachusetts at MIT.
You see, MIT, the dome
behind me, at 3:30
PM on January 6, 2021.
So I give you the when and
the where for this event.
I didn't give you the
altitude, for example.
This is, in this picture,
maybe the y-coordinate
or the z-coordinate.
But that would be
needed as well.
I just tell you, maybe it's
my office on the fourth floor
in building 24.
So when we want to consider
an event describing the event,
we have to consider the
space, so where, and the time,
the when.
And we can do this as a
four dimensional vector
or a four vector data set.
And so our event,
Professor Kloots exploded,
can be described
with this vector
P, which has an x-coordinate,
a y-coordinate, a z-coordinate,
and a time coordinate.
So the important part here is
that events happen independent
on the frame of reference.
If you are sitting in your room
somewhere in Europe right now,
you can describe this
event with your time frame.
There's a six hour
time difference.
So this 3:30 PM would be
9:30 PM in the evening.
You can define your
little room as the origin
and then draw an x-coordinate
and a y-coordinate
and z-coordinate that
describes this specific event.
This description
will look different
from the description
I just gave you.
But the event is unchanged.
It's independent of the
choice of reference.